the u.s. claims it's thinking of
Huawei's customers a 90-day reprieve
means select American companies will be
able to continue working with the
Chinese firm to ensure existing users of
its smartphones and networks don't
suffer too much disruption but Huawei
hasn't exactly showered the white house
with thanks in an interview where the
Chinese news site founder Ren Zhong Fei
said the US had underestimated Huawei
strength and ability to make its own
components some analysts agree that what
might have seemed like a setback for the
company could prove a major opportunity
they are already in the cheap phone
market and so this is gonna actually
make make it probably better for them
that they have something in-house that
could work they could actually make
phones even cheaper and sell it in other
markets the easing of restrictions comes
a day after Google barred Huawei from
some updates to its Android operating
system showing the types of challenges
that could lie ahead for the company but
the US isn't pulling the plug completely
for now at least
let's talk a little bit about that with
our financial market correspondent alas
Hato joins us in Frankfort last first of
all I mean what's prompted to this let's
just call it a change of heart well
Monica may be president Trump has just
heard from his own tech companies in
Silicon Valley who are sailing to lose a
lot of money if he bands who away from
being a customer Google has a who away
of course as a major customer with his
Android system but also chip makers like
stylings for Intel they are selling a
lot of chips - who away as well
all in all about 70% of what goes into a
Huawei cell phone actually comes from
the United States and so of course
there's a whole lot of companies that
stand to lose some money here and you
saw that clearly in the stock market
yesterday 2-1 shares for the entire tech
sector were actually down maybe not only
on Huawei specifically but on the
question if this starts with go away
where else is going okay so what does
this mean for your way then I mean they
seem determined and saying that we can
go it alone
well it gives them at least a little bit
of time it gives them 90 days now to
continue stockpiling they have done that
anyway but it also gives them a little
bit of time to just come up with their
own new options like building their own
software so but of course it's gonna
take a lot of time it also puts a lot of
pressure of course on the Chinese
government to come back to the table and
maybe make it deal with President Trump
in the trade war the way Trump wants it
all right lass hotter there in Frankfurt
thank you so much